foreign
this is the hell that's lissy Shanks and
it's a hell that never Falls silent
look to the right of that huge black
plume of smoke
that fresh puff is yet another shell
exploding on an horizon already foggy
with destruction
the cities being surrounded by Russian
troops bit by Bloody bit this bridge
over the railway was the main route in
the Russian circles nearly complete
the attackers are using Brute Force to
Sledgehammer their way in from several
directions we drove in as they mounted
their latest ferocious Onslaught on the
city's oil refinery the second largest
in Ukraine
it felt akin to riding into some sort of
Armageddon at this point Lucy Shanks is
the last stronghold in the lahance
region of the donbass losing this city
will be a Monumental loss
part of the plant is on fire many other
areas have been hit badly there are
shells coming in every few minutes and
were with the last group who've decided
it's time to leave as well
but the ukrainians are fighting the
fight of their lives
and they've been battling over this
pocket of the donbass for months
we're with the soldiers of the 24th
Brigade sworn to secrecy about their
exact location inside the plant they're
pulling out of the refinery to another
fighting position the Russian troops are
only 500 meters away and they've come
under Savage attack here
they're bitterly disappointed about
losing their Twin City of several
Donetsk a few days earlier it's made
their defensive lissy Shanks all the
more important
they don't want to give up an inch of
territory but they follow their orders
yes he says it was right to give up
severeign to save lives
but every bit swallowed up by the
Russians hurts deeply and their enemies
are making slow but steady progress
Ive
we are leaving the Battalion Commander
tells us but he doesn't see this as
defeat more a tactical withdrawal
like severe danette's beforehand they're
anxious to avoid large-scale deaths and
injuries
but even as they hastily relocated there
was an air of this being the final
battle for Lucy Shanks
they've held the Russians at Bay foreign
forcing some heavy losses on them and
buying time to build up defenses in
Donetsk the second half of the donbass
where the Russians will move to next
but they're coming under intense
pressure on the donbass battlefield and
even relocating involves casualties as
they're forced to run the gauntlet of
fresh shelling
amid the Mayhem of this Grim fighting
the explosions and hurry to shift has
led to a head-on crash
the injured are having to be rapidly
extracted and treated whilst the heavy
smog offers them some slight cover
those who make it out alive from the
line of fire are utterly exhausted and
high on relief and almost surprised
they're still in one piece
previous hello but there's a growing
exasperation at what they see is the
delay in sending long-range artillery
and better weapons for them to somehow
finish this fighting
but if you send us some new weapons are
you struggling with the stuff you've got
at the moment well can't tell that we're
struggling but it would be much better
you know they take High losses we need
to retreat but in the end again they
will go for it again we'll beat them
with artillery they will again they have
a great amount of losses so what what's
your message to Nato and the rest of
Europe
the foot soldiers aren't mincing their
words anymore
but there's a determination and courage
here that far outstrips the diminishing
odds of Victory even as they race to a
front to replace colleagues and where
they're vastly outnumbered and
outflanked
fine so I'm getting the impression
they're still very optimistic what's
your feeling
19 year old Eugene has her face etched
with the grime of war and seeing friends
die in several Donetsk he spent four
months sleeping and battling inside this
armored vehicle
he's old enough to fight and nearly die
but young enough to question withdrawing
from Lucy shanks
um
foreign
but the city is city has changed beyond
recognition with every major landmark in
the center damaged or destroyed
it's a mass of debris and destruction
the city's authorities and police say
already about three quarters of the area
is devastated
there are several thousand residents
still here
where the rumble of deadly Weaponry is
now part of their daily routine and
increased with a Savage intensity over
the past few days
foreign
hear that whistle and that crunch we
know that they're coming from the south
of the city where there's a column of
Russian Armory which is trying to
encircle the city and they keep Landing
minute every two minutes
the sun sets on lissy Shanks with
residents acutely aware these are the
final few days under Ukrainian control
even in the shelters everyone sleeps
with the rumble of War above ground all
night
we've agreed not to film those who we're
Sheltering with but there are many
families with young children here
the first sounds at dawn in the city are
always the same now
[Music]
the whistle of incoming fire from close
by Russian positions
and they're getting closer by the hour
we spot the ukrainians driving back
captured Russian armor their blue and
yellow flag flying above it now
foreign
shells with more deadly repetition
forcing the Curious nearby residents to
take cover all the time
the ukrainians are inflicting some
serious casualties on their Russian
enemies but it's still not enough to
hold them back
civilians lead us to the body of a
Russian soldier which they say was
dumped out of the captured personnel
carrier
he'd obviously been badly hurt and had a
tourniquet around his leg
the discarded Russian army uniforms have
been laid out for the residents to see
while the police document all the
evidence for any future investigation
including exactly how he died and what
he was doing
with no electricity there's no operating
morgue but his DNA will be taken to try
to identify him
is
volunteers have the awful task of
bagging the courts
[Applause]
then the body is loaded into one of the
few operating vehicles in the city a
larda so small one of the volunteers has
to sit cradling the dead Russian soldier
on his lap whilst his colleagues finish
up Gathering his personal items both
life and death in Lucy Shanks is utterly
surreal
unbeknown to us Russian media is now
broadcasting images of their troops
inside the city's oil refinery where we
saw such Savage engagement the day
before
the plant is only six miles from the
city center
in the Heart of the City where we are
the ukrainians are trying to keep them
from coming any further for as long as
possible
but this enemy is smashing its way in
okay they're Landing every few minutes
and this one's been quite close
the city has been bombed to bits
Vitali wanted the police still here
cannot believe the level of Destruction
about 70 percent of the city center has
gone
I think that the infrastructure of
the chance will be destroyed as several
Donuts infrastructure
similar about that several Donetsk is
just over this bombed bridge now under
Russian control Lily Shanks is on the
brink of being next
Aid Center after Aid Center has been
shattered this seems a deliberate
attempt to starve the city into
submission
so this used to be a humanitarian Hub
and you can see it
it's absolutely destroyed by fire
by all sorts
and they're coming under continual
sustained attack
the Russians are destroying everything
in their path
if and when they do finally take over
Lisa Shanks they're going to inherit a
pile of rubble
it's down to a few Brave volunteers to
deliver any Aid
there are about 10 to 15 000 people
still in Lucy Shanks and they're very
divided over who's to blame for all this
many like Svetlana don't want to leave
the tally the volunteer has brought a
few essentials all desperately hard to
get hold of now
her husband fedier shows us the bunker
where they flee when the shelling's too
intense
fedier doesn't buy into the Western War
narrative he lives in a very pro-russian
area and is reluctant to say who is the
aggressor is
mission
there's a deep suspicion about Ukrainian
soldiers here where pro-russian
separatists have made their mark
Misery the daily even hourly struggle to
survive is blamed on them
even finding water is a mission
and listen to what they're singing
it's a Soviet Victory tune
where are you from another asks us
um
at one of the city's Lakes where they're
getting water few will talk to us this
group blames the Ukrainian government
and all supporting them who do you blame
for the for the whole thing
foreign
the trees offer some visual cover but no
one feels safe here no one is safe and
every hour the city edges closer to
being cut off
so in this crazy Urban Battlefield
contact from far away family brings
tears and joy
very worried about the Russians coming
neighbors find themselves on opposite
sides of this war foreign
but there's no sign of an end at all
these Ukrainian special forces inside
the city center are part of the troops
stopping the Russians from entering
each delay allows time for more
bolstering of defensive positions
elsewhere
but for every inch of territory the
Russian troops are paying for it heavily
in lives and equipment
and there are frantic last attempts to
persuade people to leave
[Music]
um
[Applause]
he isn't convinced many fear they'll
never return if they leave
but some have no choice
hernadi's held out so long but with the
fighting almost on his doorstep he's
taking probably his last chance to leave
among those fleeing a young mother and
her teenage son a few hours earlier they
were scrambling out of their burning
home after it was hit her husband didn't
make it they have no idea where they're
going or where they'll stay
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
they flee as Russian troops have all but
surrounded this city losing humans
losing the whole of one half of the
donbass but the miracle is how long the
ukrainians have held out here for
those Left Behind have been caught
between two armies
the Russians deny their targeting
civilians but plenty of homes have been
hit in the fight to seize this city
a few meters away from the flames in
this building we find ehore a pensioner
who's struggling to accept his Flats
been bombed overnight both floors above
his are burned right through
are you still are you still staying in
there
with smoking Flats all around his
determined sprinkling of water to bring
down the heat doesn't seem nearly enough
to stop the fire's March yet the pain of
giving up what's his is too much
and it's this refusal to give in that
we've seen repeated over and over again
in this country